I'll now show you how to convert a
fraction into a decimal and if we have
time maybe we'll learn how to do a
decimal into a fraction so let's start
with what I would say is a fairly
straightforward example let's start with
the fraction 1/2 and I want to convert
that into a decimal so this the what the
method I'm going to show you will always
work what you do is you take the
denominator and you divide it into the
numerator let's see how that works so we
take the denominator is 2 and we're
going to divide that into the numerator
1 and you're probably saying well how do
I divide 2 into 1 well if you remember
from the dividing decimals module we can
just add a decimal point here and add
some trailing zeroes right we haven't
actually changed the value of the number
but we're just getting some precision
here we put the decimal point here 2
goes into 1 does this to go into 1 no 2
goes into 10 so we go 2 goes into 10 5
times 5 times 2 is 10 remainder 0 we're
done so 1/2 is equal to 0.5
let's do a harder slightly harder one
let's figure out one-third well once
again we take the denominator 3 and we
divide it into the numerator and I'm
just going to add a bunch of trailing
zeroes here 3 goes into well 3 doesn't
go into 1 3 goes into 10 three times 3
times 3 is 9 subtract get a 1 bring down
the 0 3 goes into 10 three times and
actually this decimal point is right
here 3 times 3 is 9 okay do you see a
pattern here we keep getting the same
thing as you see it's actually 0.33 3 3
it goes on forever and a way to actually
represent this if obviously you can't
write an infinite number of threes is
you could just write point well you
could write 0.33 repeating which means
that the 0.33 will go on forever or you
could actually even say 0.3 repeating
although I tend to see this more often
maybe I'm just mistaken but in general
this line on top of the decimal means
that this
these this number pattern repeats
indefinitely so 1/3 is equal to 0.33 3 3
3 and goes on forever and that's equal
to another way of writing that is 0.33
repeating let's do a couple of maybe a
little bit harder but they're they all
follow the same pattern let me pick some
weird numbers let me say let me she do
an improper fraction let me say 17 over
9 so here it's interesting the numerator
is bigger than denominator so actually
we're going to the number larger than 1
but let's let's work it out so we take 9
and we divide it into 17 and let's add
some trailing zeroes for the decimal
point here so 9 goes into 17 one time 1
times 9 is 9 17 minus 9 is 8 bring down
a 0 9 goes into 80 well we know 9 times
9 is 81 so it has to go into it only 8
times because can't go into 9 times 8
times 9 is 72 80 minus 72 is 8 bring
that another zero I think we see a
pattern forming again 9 goes into 80
eight times 8 times 9 is 72 and clearly
I could keep doing this forever and we
keep getting eighths so we see 17
divided by 9 is equal to one point eight
eight where the point eight eight
actually repeats forever or if we
actually wanted to round this we could
say that that is also equal to one point
depending where we wanted to round it
what place we could say you know roughly
1 point 8 9 or we could round at a
different place I round it in the
hundreds place but this is the actually
the exact answer 17 over 9 is equal to
one point eight eight actually I do a
separate module but how would we write
this as a mixed number well well
actually I'm gonna do that in a separate
I don't want to confuse you for now
let's do a couple more problems
let me do a real weird one let me do
seventeen over 93 what does that equal
as a decimal well we do the same thing
93 goes into Ceph I make a really long
line up here because I don't know how
long how many decimal places will do and
remember it's always the denominator
being divided into the numerator
let's usually confused me a lot of times
because you're often dividing a larger
number into a smaller number so 93 goes
into 17 zero times right there's a
decimal 93 goes into 170 goes into it
one time one times 93 is 93 170 minus 93
is 77 bring down the zero
93 goes into 770 let's see it'll go into
it I think roughly eight times times 3
is 24 8 times 9 is 72 plus 2 is 74 and
then we subtract 10 6 is equal to 26
let me bring down another 0 9 3 goes
into 26 probably sees about 2 times 2
times 3 is 6 18 this is 74 zero so we
could keep going this is actually we
could keep figuring out the decimal
points you could do this indefinitely
but if you want to at least get an
approximation you would say 17 goes into
93 point or 17 over 93 is equal to 0.18
- and then the decimals will keep going
and you could keep doing it if you want
if you actually saw this in exam they
probably tell you to stop at some point
you know round it to the nearest
hundredths or thousands place and let
this just so you know let's let's try to
convert it the other way from decimals
to fractions actually this is this is I
think
you'll find a much easier thing to do if
I were to ask you what 0.035 is as a
fraction well all you do is you say well
0.035 that is the same thing as we could
we could write it this way we could
write that's the same thing as well let
me that's the same thing as 0 3 well I
shouldn't write 0 3 5 that's the same
thing as 35 over 1,000 and you're
probably saying Sal how did you know
it's 35 over a thousand well because we
went to 3 this is the tens place the
tenths not tens this is hundreds this is
a thousandths place right so we went to
three decimals of significance so this
is 35 thousandths if the if the decimal
was let's say if it was point zero three
zero there's a couple of ways we could
say this well we could say oh well we
got to three we went to the thousands
place so this is the same thing as 30
over a thousand or we could have also
said well point zero three zero is the
same thing as point zero three because
this zero really doesn't add any value
like it so if we have point zero three
then we're going to the hundredths place
so this is the same thing as 3 over 100
so let me ask you are these two the same
well yeah sure they are if we divide
both the numerator and the denominator
of both of these expressions by 10 we
get 3 over 100 well let's go back to
this case are we done with this is 35
over 1000 I mean it's it's right that is
a fraction 35 over a thousand but if we
wanted to simplify it even more it looks
like we could divide both the numerator
and the denominator by 5 and then just
just to get it into simplest form that
equals 7 over 200 and if we wanted to
convert 7 over 200 into a decimal using
the technique we just did so we
we do 200 goes into seven and figure it
out
we should get 0.035 I'll leave that up
to you as an exercise
hopefully now you get at least a initial
understanding of how to convert a
fraction into a decimal and maybe a vice
versa and if you don't just do some of
the practices and I will also try to
record another module on this or another
presentation have fun with the exercises